because if you never set yourself goals
you can never question yourself because
you just move from one to the next and
you say it's going to be okay in tennis
working on your weaknesses makes it
maybe an overall complete player but you
won't be dangerous anymore as long as I
enjoy what I'm doing a train hard have
no regrets and all I can do is give my
best then it's going to be fine
regardless of the outcome I don't think
it's enough just to love it and then
just to do it and go out and win it it's
important for me to actually hear
criticism sometimes you know because I
think that's what makes me a better
player if you prepare you don't panic
for me it's the same thing if I'm
winning or losing I need to concentrate
on what was my game plan I used to work
with a mental trainer but that was when
I was probably 16 17 because I was just
I just had bad behavior the moment I
left the the tennis courts I tried to
forget what I just did on the tennis
court for at least a moment my dream was
always to get number one in the world
and just want to try my best for that oh
it's all talent doesn't work I just sit
on the couch
he's a swiss professional tennis player
he's regarded by many to be the greatest
tennis player of all time he was named
world sportsman of the year for a record
four consecutive years
he's Roger Federer and here are his top
ten rules for success
for me a very important of the short
term goals and the long term is where do
I want to be in six months time because
if you never set yourself goals you can
never question yourself because you just
move from one to the next and you say
it's going to be okay and the best thing
I've done to be honest in the last 10
years I think it was questioning myself
at the best of times when things are
going great what more can I do how much
better can I become how much harder can
I train incredible let's hope that it's
okay
what an amazing [ __ ] backhand from
Federer
yeah he's fine just a little shocked
remember where your roots are and
remember where your strengths lie I
think is especially also important for
me and I always believed these are my
strengths and this is what either in
tennis I work on or these are my
strengths in my personality and this is
what also maybe people want to see and
hear and feel I think many people always
feel like they have to work on their
weaknesses you know I mean I don't know
how he works in the business world as
much but in anyway in in tennis working
on your weaknesses makes it maybe an
overall complete player but you won't be
dangerous anymore you know so I think
you can sometimes relate to that in some
businesses as well that's why I like to
work on the strengths and its really
helped me through throughout my career
you know it starts very locally and so
forth and you move on and on and on and
and you have to prove yourself time and
time again and that pressure can
definitely weigh on you you lose the fun
goes away sometimes just because instead
of now it being this life long dream
you've had of wanting just to enjoy
yourself and play tennis like your
heroes used to people sort of expect you
to win like losing in the quarterfinals
which was a dream five years ago now is
like a disaster it's it changes the
mindset of you as a player and as a
professional athlete and that's where I
always try to remember well you know
what as long as I enjoy what I'm doing a
train hard have no regrets and all I can
do is give my best then it's going to be
fine regardless of the outcome how did
you get to a point where you could have
that kind of perspective in your career
took me a while to be honest I was very
emotional when I was younger so I think
by the age of 22 maybe I thought 25
maybe I'd say even I was like okay
losing is fine you know but I think that
only came because I I want that much all
of a sudden so I knew that those wins
nobody could take away from me that's
sort of in the vault
that's good to have good to know and now
you have to just prove yourself every
single day and everything that comes is
like a bonus so I've been on this bonus
trip since a long long time and playing
this way it's been actually much more
enjoyable even though you know chasing
records and playing against the other
top guys and there has also created its
own pressure you know but a different
one then when you're up and coming and
trying to make the break so it's quite
challenging and especially you're young
and you're emotional
it's it's it's quite difficult
goodness
Starlin where he left off yesterday
and they'll punch Oh we'll have to look
back on this point say I couldn't have
done any better
he really did I mean that was just a
remarkable shot but open court or no a
dangerous place to put the ball
run with the forehand I don't think it's
enough just to love it and then just to
do it and go out and win it it's not
that simple you need to have structured
goals you need to tell yourself okay
what are my goals for the short-term
what are my goals for the long-term now
that I've accomplished almost everything
and I'm supposed to go out on the tennis
court singing let's just pay free it's
hit the ball who cares you know but this
is not how you're going to win matches
because it comes down to margins and you
have to be so clear in your mind exactly
what you want to do and what you want to
achieve and for me it doesn't work
without any goals without any targets I
cannot compete properly
well I think the team is always very
important you know in any aspect of of
your life if it's in business or in your
in your life you know to have a good
team good friends around you it's key to
be able to pick the right ones is
another quality I think you know leaders
tend to have for me always harmony and
the team has been very important but
also people who can challenge me you
know who can tell me Roger don't you
think you should change this we have an
idea for you a solution maybe two
problems and I'm very happy if they tell
me that if they do see a problem or they
think that I can still improve it's
important for me to actually hear
criticism sometimes you know because I
think that's what makes me a better
player and it questions I that means
someone's questioning me who really
cares about me and I think that's really
important in the business world as well
and you know I think I've done actually
quite well over the over the years
considering always having a team around
me for the last 12 years
my word
we've been written off at times this
year but when you watch a shot lighter
out he's playing better than ever
Oh Sean Cassius AK you think you can do
it as well he's the president of French
Tennis Federation he's an international
rugby player at heart and he knows a
little bit of brilliance when he sees it
you know it's like in school if we think
back when we went to school and be
prepared for a test and the plate the
paper comes in front of you if were you
prepared you don't panic for me it's the
same thing if I'm winning or losing I
need to concentrate on what was my game
plan what did I come here to do I'll try
okay maybe make it a more physical match
if it's going to easy for the opponent
adjust a little bit but not really go
completely off track
you want to see
federer waving his Wilson one more
moment of genius I used to work with a
mental trainer but that was when I was
probably 16 17 because I was just I just
had bad behavior more than anything and
I'm happy I was able to get away from
that no more breaking racquets and was
throwing you know stuff around no more
complaining no more commentating my own
points at each time but at the end of
the day was myself who had to convince
myself of changing and I was only able
to change that when I was about 20 I
think it's important to learn from
mistakes and losses because usually
learn more there than from wins it's
it's natural
okay
and for my next act
while they saw me in work life silence
I'm trying to get this one okay the
moment I left the the tennis courts I
tried to forget what I just did on the
tennis court for at least a moment okay
the back of your mind you have to say
the businessperson or you have to stay
the tennis player just too because
that's who you are you know that's your
number one priority maybe next to your
family if you have a knot but so that to
me was always really key and I think
honestly I've mastered cutting the two
things from each other
you know the business world to the
private the personal life
I'm more go like on I would say year by
year are we add what try to reach top 15
till the end of this year and I want my
goal was also to win a title that's what
I've done already so I want to get more
now of course after winning my first one
and otherwise I mean in five years I
haven't thought about it at all yet but
my dream was always to get number one in
the world and just I'm gonna try my best
for that because it's a kid's dream for
me
Kaneesha pause until Manny pika
Kanter who is your
how do to be such a good movie
it's awesome - yelling - give us four
buckles do you train really hard in the
offseason can you give me any tips
anything you can talk about oh it's old
talent doesn't work I just sit on the
couch you you thought you had something
going right that you were one of those
like was Linda that you know made us
generation work hard not with me anyway
I didn't get inspired no all I do is
really just take care of the kids you
know I won't say no if Andy Murray
decides now all right she's a nice guy
Raj is a father and let's I won't say no
but
he'd like to win the first four British
Tennyson's what is 850,000 years so I'm
just happy waking up in the morning and
feeling like an old man so that's very
positive I felt like that you're looking
right at me when you say that thanks
buddy
appreciate that you know that old a
little bit old
how's he hitting him he warmed me up and
I won very well
the interview was great but then I
needed Roger to stick around so I could
ask a few questions in Spanish for a CNN
in his final programming because you
don't have to do anything I'm just gonna
read out some questions on Spanish just
a couple of questions while while you're
in shot okay um another need to answer
them no you don't need to answer them at
all here we go ustedes son hombre record
it's tough I tell you except Rishi
no it's okay I can I can keep going even
if you're smiling I'll keep going no if
you crack up that's when I lose it okay
okay don't worry okay you stay there
soon hombre since this is for Latin
American maybe I can and do one more
about today that's given to them alright
Chuck that's why shut your eyes Roger
good yeah I don't have to like it's just
the back exit can I shut my eyes okay
all right three two can't believe is
closing his eyes this is hilarious I've
never asked someone a question when
they're closing down
now could give thank you so much for
watching I made this video because a
world girl asks me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave in the comments below
and see what I can do I also love to
know which of Rogers top 10 rules meant
the most to you is gonna have the
biggest impact leaving the comments
below and I'll join the discussion thank
you so much for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon